This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的迹象。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people listen to look back at it on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts hey what's good y'all you're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host care games this space is about black men's experiences having honest conversations
与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话。
that's really not safe to have anywhere but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing how many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you not to be played with and just because you have the capabilities that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
在任何地方进行这些对话其实都不安全，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着这一季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s
他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变的播客。
and what they mean for our psychosies. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s today. I have something really fun and scientific for you guys. So if your favorite episodes of the podcast are when we kind of go deep into concepts and deep into research, you are going to love today. today's topic, and even if you don't, I still think this is one of those ones you should definitely listen to because it will tell you so much about how you operate, your behaviors, your decision making, while you make decisions that you don't always actually want to make rationally,
以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到播客。很高兴你们能回来收听新的一集，当然，今天我们要剖析20多岁的心理学。今天我为你们准备了一些非常有趣且科学的内容。所以，如果你最喜欢的播客剧集是那种我们深入探讨概念和研究的内容，你一定会喜欢今天的话题。即使你不喜欢，我仍然认为这是你绝对应该听的一集，因为它会告诉你很多关于你是如何运作的、你的行为、你的决策，以及为什么你会做出那些你并不总是想理性做出的决定。
because today we are talking about the conscious versus unconscious mind and the role each of them plays in our lives and why we kind of, again, yeah, make decisions that feel bizarre. are and hard to justify while we have these reactions that come out of nowhere and yet we still keep doing them and we can't quite figure out how to change. This is the unconscious mind. This is the part of our existence and how we interpret the world we're going to really drill into today. The idea that there are parts of us operating outside of our deliberate rational control is not a new idea. What's just changed over time and over the years is how we explain it. And we cannot talk about the unconscious versus conscious mind without doing a little bit of a history lesson first.
因为今天我们要讨论的是意识与潜意识，以及它们各自在我们生活中扮演的角色，以及为什么我们又会做出那些感觉离奇且难以证明的决定，为什么我们会有那些凭空出现的反应，但我们却一直在重复它们，却无法弄清楚如何改变。这就是潜意识。这就是我们今天将要深入探讨的我们存在的一部分以及我们如何解读世界的方式。认为我们身上存在着超出我们审慎理性控制的部分，这并不是一个新观点。随着时间的推移和岁月的流逝，改变的只是我们解释它的方式。在不先上一堂历史课的情况下，我们无法谈论潜意识与意识。
So long before we had these words that I think we use so often these days, unconscious, conscious, subconscious, a lot of brilliant ancient thinkers were describing basically the same thing. This feeling that we as humans are split between what we, we know rationally and how we choose to behave emotionally. This goes like all the way back to like Plato and Aristotle and Spinoza who basically distinguished between what they called intuitive passions or appetites and then on the other hand deliberate reason. Plato for example, I like this metaphor. He described the human soul as having three parts and he kind of described it as if we are sitting behind a chariot. And the chariot represents us and represents our
所以，早在我们拥有这些如今经常使用的词汇——潜意识、意识、下意识——之前，许多杰出的古代思想家就已经在描述基本相同的事情了。这种感觉，即我们作为人类，被我们理性所知的和我们选择如何感性地表现出来所分裂。这可以追溯到柏拉图、亚里士多德和斯宾诺莎，他们基本上区分了他们所谓的直觉激情或欲望，以及另一方面，审慎的理性。例如，柏拉图，我喜欢这个隐喻。他描述人类灵魂有三个部分，他把它描述得好像我们坐在战车后面。战车代表我们，代表我们的
reason. And we think we're the ones that are guiding it. But really what's guiding the chariot are these two horses. We're guided by these two, in his mind, two winged horses. One represented nobility. It represented our emotional and social knowledge and our desire to be good and to be reasonable and rational. And then the other horse represented like our wild side. Like it represented our desire and the appetite of like the unbounded parts of the soul. That is a very early representation of how we might now view our rational mind and how we might also view our impulses and emotions or our, I guess beliefs or our social behavior, each of them leading us in different directions. If this sounds familiar to Freud's idea of the ego and the super ego and the id, it's because it is.
理性。我们认为是我们自己在引导它。但实际上引导战车的是这两匹马。在他看来，我们被这两匹带翅膀的马引导着。一匹代表高贵。它代表我们的情感和社会知识，以及我们想要变得善良、合理和理性的愿望。而另一匹马则代表了我们的野性一面。它代表了我们的欲望和灵魂中无拘无束部分的食欲。这是我们现在如何看待我们的理性思维，以及我们如何看待我们的冲动和情感，或者我猜是信念或社会行为的一个非常早期的表现，它们各自引导我们走向不同的方向。如果这听起来很像弗洛伊德的自我、超我和本我的概念，那是因为它确实如此。
Freud took a lot of his ideas from Plato and some of these ancient thinkers. He is obviously one of the most famous psychoanalysts of all time. And yeah, he based a lot of his work and the foundation of a lot of his theories on some of these metaphors. and he kind of took those initial ideas and tried to format them or flash them out even more. And in his mind, the mind is divided into three parts. The conscious mind, so what you're aware of right now, you know, I'm sitting in this room, I'm looking around, there's a microphone in front of me, I'm recording my podcast, my pre-conscious mind, things that are kind of just sitting below that I want to talk about,
弗洛伊德从柏拉图和这些古代思想家那里汲取了很多想法。他显然是有史以来最著名的精神分析学家之一。是的，他将他的大部分工作和许多理论的基础建立在这些隐喻之上。他采纳了那些最初的想法，并试图将它们格式化或进一步充实。在他看来，心灵分为三个部分。意识，也就是你现在意识到的东西，你知道，我坐在这个房间里，我环顾四周，我面前有一个麦克风，我正在录制我的播客；我的前意识，那些就在那之下，我想谈论的事情，
where this idea is going, what I have to do next, how my mood is. being impacted by things that happened earlier this morning, and then the unconscious mind. Material that to him is kept out of awareness, but it's still influencing you. So you may have seen this, especially in like psych 101 classes, represented as an iceberg. That's a pretty classic way of representing it. I still remember having that I spoke diagram in my psych textbooks. But all of these things, the conscious subconscious or pre-conscious and unconscious, all kind of work together to form the person that we know as ourselves.
这个想法要去向何方，我接下来要做什么，我的情绪是如何受到今天早上早些时候发生的事情的影响的，然后是潜意识。对他来说，那些被排除在意识之外，但仍在影响你的材料。所以你可能在心理学入门课上见过这个，它被表现为一座冰山。这是一种非常经典的表现方式。我仍然记得在我的心理学教科书中看到过那个冰山图。但所有这些东西，意识、潜意识或前意识和潜意识，都以某种方式共同作用，形成了我们所知的我们自己。
One thing Freud really emphasized, though, was the role of dreams in being able to basically understand what the unconscious mind is doing below the surface. So in his mind, like, we could never directly know what's happening unconsciously in our mind. He basically said that dreams are one of the only ways. of really being able to understand what's going on. He wrote a whole book about it. It's literally called The Interpretation of Dreams. He also claimed that, you know, our dreams fulfilled our unconscious wishes.
然而，弗洛伊德确实强调了一点，那就是梦在理解潜意识在表面之下做什么方面的作用。所以在他看来，我们永远无法直接知道我们潜意识里发生了什么。他基本上说梦是唯一的方法之一。真正能够理解正在发生的事情。他为此写了一整本书。书名就叫《梦的解析》。他还声称，你知道，我们的梦实现了我们潜意识的愿望。
So, like, if you want to be famous, your dreams may reveal to you how you should do that. Or, you know, if you feel guilty, your dreams may reveal to you how you're not or how you should forgive yourself. He also says they reveal what we desire most or what we fear the most. Some other ways that he said we could get in touch with the unconscious mind were the famous Freudian slip, artwork, repressed memories. These days, we know that's all probably less and accurate. There may be some slight truth to it, some slight truth to our dreams, kind of working out some deep emotional wounds, but Freud did get a lot of stuff wrong. I think he did the best that he could with what he had, but he's still a controversial figure.
所以，如果你想出名，你的梦可能会向你揭示你应该如何做到这一点。或者，你知道，如果你感到内疚，你的梦可能会向你揭示你如何不内疚，或者你应该如何原谅自己。他还说它们揭示了我们最渴望什么或最害怕什么。他说我们可以接触潜意识的其他一些方式是著名的弗洛伊德式口误、艺术作品、被压抑的记忆。如今，我们知道这些可能都不太准确。它可能有一点点真实性，对我们的梦有一点点真实性，某种程度上解决了一些深层的情感创伤，但弗洛伊德确实弄错了很多东西。我认为他用他所拥有的东西尽了最大的努力，但他仍然是一个有争议的人物。
And this is a great place to kind of shift gears and talk about what we know about the unconscious and conscious mind now in the modern day with a bit more technology, with a bit more scientific experimental practice going on. Pretty simply, the conscious mind in psychological terms is the set of mental processes that you can deliberately direct. what you can hold in awareness, what you can reason about, what you can talk about, what you can see. The big thing about the conscious mind, sorry, is that it's relatively slow. It's very intentional, effortful. It's kind of limited in its capacity as well. So, for example, you can't, you really can't juggle more than a couple of things in your conscious mind at any one time. It's why we're bad at multitasking.
这是一个转换话题的好地方，谈谈我们在现代社会中对潜意识和意识的了解，有了更多的技术，有了更多的科学实验实践。简单地说，心理学意义上的意识是一组你可以审慎引导的心理过程。你可以保持在意识中的东西，你可以推理的东西，你可以谈论的东西，你可以看到的东西。关于意识，抱歉，最重要的一点是它相对缓慢。它非常刻意，费力。它的容量也有限。所以，例如，你不能，你真的不能在任何时候在你的意识中同时处理几件事。这就是为什么我们不擅长多任务处理。
It's why we get mentally overwhelmed. It's why you say things automatically. you don't really mean when a lot's going on around you. I like to think of your conscious mind as like the spokesperson. It is the person that like the company puts in front of the cameras who is like reading off the script that the unconscious mind has given it. Or it's kind of more like it's putting together a speech from a bunch of dot points that the unconscious mind has given it.
这就是为什么我们感到精神崩溃。这就是为什么当你周围发生很多事情时，你会自动说出你并不真正想说的话。我喜欢把你的意识想象成发言人。它是公司放在摄像机前的人，他正在阅读潜意识给他的脚本。或者更像是它正在从潜意识给它的一堆要点中整理出一篇演讲稿。
It has some decision making powers. It directs a small amount of information. it definitely applies a lot of reason and it interprets the small things that the unconscious mind gives it. But beyond like directing impulses and directing things around you, it also doesn't completely, your conscious mind cannot be aware of absolutely everything. It's just responsible for constructing the source. story of who you are based on what it has access to. Just basically, it interprets your human experience for you, but it doesn't always have a
它有一些决策权。它引导少量信息。它绝对应用了很多理性，并解释了潜意识给它的微小事物。但除了引导冲动和引导你周围的事物之外，它也不能完全，你的意识无法意识到绝对的一切。它只负责构建故事。基于它所能访问的内容，关于你是谁的故事。基本上，它为你解释你的人类体验，但它并不总是有一个
good grip on everything that's going on in kind of the back offices of the mind, right? Again, think of this spokesperson or CEO analogy. Let's use the CEO analogy. The CEO may be up front, but she is like nothing without the staff whose jobs she can't possibly do all by herself. And she can't possibly be aware of everything that's going on in the back offices all the time. That's the unconscious mind. The conscious mind is just the front man. There's a lot going on behind the scenes. One key aspect that the unconscious mind is responsible for is rapid evaluation that our conscious mind just isn't quick enough for. You know, whether something
对心灵后台正在发生的一切有很好的把握，对吧？再次，想想这个发言人或CEO的类比。让我们使用CEO的类比。CEO可能在前面，但如果没有那些她自己根本无法完成工作的员工，她什么也不是。而且她不可能时刻意识到后台正在发生的一切。那就是潜意识。意识只是门面。幕后发生了很多事情。潜意识负责的一个关键方面是快速评估，而我们的意识不够快。你知道，无论是某事
is good or bad, whether something is safe or unsafe, whether to approach or avoid, how to react in a situation of danger. Before you consciously decide how you feel about a situation or even about someone's tone or their physicality or their presence, your body often already knows. Automatic evaluations, they are what help us really move quickly in social and physical environments. For example, if you meet somebody and you instantly feel uneasy but you can't explain why, that's your unconscious mind.
是好是坏，某事是安全还是不安全，是接近还是回避，在危险情况下如何反应。在你自觉地决定你对某种情况的感觉，甚至是对某人的语气、身体状况或存在感的感觉之前，你的身体通常已经知道了。自动评估，它们是帮助我们在社会和物理环境中真正快速移动的东西。例如，如果你遇到某人，你立刻感到不安，但你无法解释原因，那就是你的潜意识。
like your mind has picked up on subtle cues like micro expressions or a mismatch between their words and their tone without conscious awareness. It's like that feeling in your gut, right? Interestingly, actually, maybe not a surprising fact for many people, but women are better at this. Women are better at unconsciously picking up on these micro expressions. There was a study in 2020 that basically gave participants a bunch of portraits of people, either with an authentic or an unauthentic,
就像你的大脑捕捉到了微妙的线索，比如微表情，或者他们的言语和语气之间的不匹配，而没有意识到。就像那种直觉，对吧？有趣的是，实际上，对于许多人来说，这可能不是一个令人惊讶的事实，但女性在这方面做得更好。女性在潜意识里捕捉这些微表情方面做得更好。2020年有一项研究，基本上给了参与者一堆人的肖像，要么是真实的，要么是不真实的，
non-authentic smile. Women were picking up on that incredibly quickly and with much higher accuracy. This is because your unconscious mind is also responsible for always kind of having this idea of like, what are we going to do next? Or action preparation. I.e., if this person, is dangerous, it knows what you're immediately going to do before you even know about it. It's also responsible for associative learning, right? That study, right, where these women could tell if people were inauthentic and the smile was not to be trusted, definitely your unconscious mind has picked up on times in the past where that's probably happened, where you've trusted somebody and they had a smile like that person and then they betrayed you. Or you've trusted somebody
非真实的微笑。女性捕捉到这一点非常快，而且准确率高得多。这是因为你的潜意识也负责总是保持这种想法，比如，我们接下来要做什么？或者行动准备。即，如果这个人是危险的，它在你甚至不知道之前就知道你将立即做什么。它也负责联想学习，对吧？那项研究，对吧，这些女性可以分辨出人们是否不真诚，微笑是否不可信，你的潜意识绝对捕捉到了过去可能发生这种情况的时刻，你信任某人，他们有像那个人一样的微笑，然后他们背叛了你。或者你信任某人
and they've had an authentic smile like that person and they've ended up being a great friend. Really, it's this embodied reaction. We often label it as a gut reaction that comes from all these past experiences. Childhood hurt, memories we've forgotten about that have lingered on in some form or another, often through automatic behaviours. And sometimes this is amazing, right? Intuitive reactions are really helpful. Knowing how to follow your intuition is an amazing human ability, but other times this reaction can be really faulty. It can be encoded through bias and through fear so that, you know, we often do respond in weird self-sabotaging ways or in a way that we don't really want to because our conscious mind didn't sign off on it. And that's the final thing, the unconscious
他们有像那个人一样的真诚微笑，结果他们成为了好朋友。真的，这是一种具身反应。我们经常把它标记为一种来自所有这些过去经历的直觉反应。童年的伤害，我们已经忘记但以某种形式留存下来的记忆，通常是通过自动行为。有时这很棒，对吧？直觉反应真的很有帮助。知道如何跟随你的直觉是一种惊人的人类能力，但有时这种反应可能真的有缺陷。它可以通过偏见和恐惧进行编码，以至于，你知道，我们经常以奇怪的自我破坏方式做出反应，或者以我们并不真正想要的方式做出反应，因为我们的意识没有签字。这就是最后一件事，潜意识
mind, or the theories say the unconscious mind is also really responsible for and plays a role in is your habits and your context triggered. behavior. Habits aren't just repeated actions. They are learnt links between a cue, a response, and a feeling. For example, choosing to exercise or not, yeah, your conscious mind might make the final decision. And you might think that you have a say in whether you choose to exercise tonight or not. But behind the scenes are all these associations that are pushing you towards one decision or another, like how you felt the last time you exercised, your beliefs about people who exercise, that one time you were a kid and you were picked last for the football team,
思维，或者理论说潜意识也真正负责并发挥作用的是你的习惯和你的情境触发行为。习惯不仅仅是重复的动作。它们是线索、反应和感觉之间习得的联系。例如，选择锻炼与否，是的，你的意识可能会做出最终决定。你可能认为你有权决定今晚是否选择锻炼。但在幕后，所有这些联想都在推动你做出一个或另一个决定，比如你上次锻炼时的感觉，你对锻炼的人的看法，你小时候有一次被最后选入足球队，
or you fell over and now you forever resent exercise. And there's always this like weird dark memory about it, even if you can't consciously remember that happening. Another way we see this really interestingly is with a lot of our food choices, like how we choose what we buy at the grocery store. So why is it important? important to separate the conscious from the unconscious. What does that actually help us with behaviorally and emotionally and psychologically? We're going to talk about all of that and more
或者你摔倒了，现在你永远怨恨锻炼。而且总是有关于它的奇怪黑暗记忆，即使你无法有意识地记得那件事发生。我们看到这种情况的另一种非常有趣的方式是我们的许多食物选择，比如我们如何选择在杂货店买什么。那么为什么将意识与潜意识分开很重要呢？这在行为上、情感上和心理上对我们有什么帮助？我们将讨论所有这些以及更多
and the important lessons we can really take from unconscious impulses after the short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
以及我们在短暂休息后可以从潜意识冲动中真正学到的重要教训。请留下来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学，在这个奇怪的现代世界中。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，以看穿统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。就是2%。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got? to do a little Kim.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底跟小金有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, yeah. But just so y'all know.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在这一天谈论快克，但是，是的，是的，是的。但只是为了让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我不认为对于黑人来说，有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，凯尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年来我在心理健康领域的个人经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在谈论。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。
Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，当你活在地球上时。你是一个好人吗？因为你害怕。因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023,
加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any matter. should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man.
随着这一季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。第一条规则，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条规则，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》这一新季中，天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉就像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的报应。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So why can't we just lump our conscious and our unconscious together and call it a day? Like, that's our mind. It just is what it is. Why do we actually have to understand
请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。那么为什么我们不能把我们的意识和潜意识混在一起，然后就此打住呢？就像，那是我们的心灵。它就是它。为什么我们实际上必须理解
them separately. Well, these habits we were talking about, right? Those like repetitive behaviours or things that we keep doing, that is why it's important to know what comes from your conscious goal directed you, your higher self, and what comes from something deeper. The quote I always use, I feel like I've been quoting Carl Jung a lot in recent episodes, but this quote is spectacular for what we're talking about today. one of the grandfathers of modern psychology, he said, until you make the unconscious conscious, it will direct your life and we will call it fate. And this is what we're talking about. I think a lot of us assume that we're pretty self-aware as people, especially if like you've
它们是分开的。好吧，我们刚才谈到的这些习惯，对吧？那些重复的行为或我们一直在做的事情，这就是为什么知道什么来自你的意识目标导向的你，你的更高自我，什么来自更深层的东西很重要。我总是引用的那句话，我觉得我在最近的剧集中引用了很多卡尔·荣格的话，但这句话对于我们今天讨论的内容来说非常壮观。现代心理学的祖父之一，他说，直到你使潜意识变得有意识，它将引导你的生活，而我们将称之为命运。这就是我们正在谈论的。我认为我们很多人假设我们作为人是非常有自我意识的，特别是如果你
done a lot of that deep emotional work or you've been in therapy, especially if you talk openly about your feelings. You're like, yeah, I kind of, I know myself. I know what's going on. but a lot of research says that most of these behaviors and this knowledge is really just scratching the surface. There is a pretty famous piece of literature, psychology literature, from the 1970s, where essentially these researchers, Nisbitton Wilson, realize that, wait, we really don't know why we make certain choices. We really don't know what produces our judgments. And when we're asked to explain when we make certain decisions, often we'll just give an answer that sounds reasonable,
做了很多深层的情感工作，或者你一直在接受治疗，特别是如果你公开谈论你的感受。你会说，是的，我有点，我了解我自己。我知道发生了什么。但很多研究表明，大多数这些行为和知识真的只是触及了表面。有一篇非常著名的文学作品，心理学文献，来自1970年代，基本上这些研究人员，尼斯比特和威尔逊，意识到，等等，我们真的不知道为什么我们做出某些选择。我们真的不知道是什么产生了我们的判断。当我们被要求解释我们做出某些决定时，通常我们只会给出一个听起来合理的答案，
even if that is not the true reason, just to kind of make our unconscious actions make sense. And this study was like fundamental in showing this. So essentially they put these participants in a room, or I don't know how they actually did it, whether it was one by one, I think it was. And they put them in front of like a clothing rack. And there were these series of clothing items. and they didn't have any tags on them
即使那不是真正的原因，只是为了让我们的潜意识行为变得有意义。这项研究在展示这一点方面是基础性的。所以基本上他们把这些参与者放在一个房间里，或者我不知道他们实际上是怎么做的，是一个接一个，我想是这样。他们把他们放在一个衣架前。有一系列服装项目。它们上面没有任何标签
and they just asked them to choose which item was the best. So which item was the best, had the best quality, which one did they prefer the most? The thing was, the items were almost identical. And most people chose the item that was simply the furthest to the right. They just, for whatever reason, people kept going back to this one.
他们只是要求他们选择哪件商品是最好的。所以哪件商品是最好的，质量最好，他们最喜欢哪一件？问题是，这些商品几乎是一模一样的。大多数人选择了最靠右的那一件。他们只是，无论出于什么原因，人们一直在回到这一件。
They were all the same, this one at the very end. And they would feel all these items, whether it was because it was the last item they felt because it was on the very end or the last item they saw, it didn't really matter. For some reason, they were all choosing this particular piece. And when they were asked, why did you choose this item? Participants never mentioned the positioning. They never mentioned anything about that. They weren't even consciously aware of it. Instead, they just gave these explanations like, this one has. had this very particular sense to it or this very particular texture and I could tell it was
它们都是一样的，这一件在最末端。他们会摸所有这些商品，无论是因为它是因为它是他们摸到的最后一件商品，因为它在最末端，还是他们看到的最后一件商品，这并不重要。出于某种原因，他们都选择了这一件。当被问及，你为什么选择这件商品时？参与者从未提到位置。他们从未提到关于那点的任何事情。他们甚至没有意识到这一点。相反，他们只是给出了这样的解释，比如，这一件有
better or this one, the fiber count reminded me most of like this sweater I had as a kid that my mom spent a lot of money on. Like they were just, it wasn't that they were lying. It's just that there were these underlying unconscious processes that were impacting their choices that they didn't have access to and yet their conscious mind had to justify it. And this is a way that human behavior can be manipulated. That is one of the biggest reasons why we have to understand it. The group who know a lot about this and know very well how to manipulate these unconscious shortcuts or choices are actually advertisers. And also, this may surprise you, we talked about grocery stores before the people who stock your supermarket shelves. They
这种非常特别的气味，或者这种非常特别的质地，我能看出它更好，或者这一件，纤维计数让我想起了我小时候的一件毛衣，我妈妈花了很多钱买的。就像他们只是，并不是他们在撒谎。只是有这些潜在的潜意识过程在影响他们的选择，他们无法访问，但他们的意识必须证明它是合理的。这是一种人类行为可以被操纵的方式。这就是我们必须理解它的最大原因之一。了解这一点并非常清楚如何操纵这些潜意识捷径或选择的群体实际上是广告商。而且，这可能会让你感到惊讶，我们在之前谈到了杂货店，那些在超市货架上摆放商品的人。他们
know a lot about the unconscious mind. Did you know that most of our shopping decisions, are based on placement alone. So the majority of us, if we were given, let's say, 20 options for like jam or pasta or sauce or whatever, we're just going to buy what's like directly in our line of sight, like 90% of the time. Yeah, like price and quality will sometimes come into play, but big brands will literally pay top dollar
对潜意识了解很多。你知道吗，我们大多数的购物决定，仅仅基于摆放位置。所以我们大多数人，如果我们被给予，比如说，20种果酱或意大利面或酱汁或什么的选项，我们90%的时间只是会买那些直接在我们视线范围内的东西。是的，价格和质量有时会发挥作用，但大品牌会真正支付高价
to buy shelf space right in the middle, right in that line of size. site, and that's why the most popular brands will often sit there. Even if you choose not to buy that product, why you buy a different one is also due to your unconscious mind. For example, supermarkets always put the most expensive items at the top. That slightly higher price makes it feel slightly better and makes you feel slightly better about yourself being able to afford something that isn't the basic choice because it feeds
购买就在中间，就在那个视线范围内的货架空间，这就是为什么最受欢迎的品牌通常会坐在那里。即使你选择不买那个产品，你买另一个的原因也是由于你的潜意识。例如，超市总是把最昂贵的商品放在最上面。那个稍微高一点的价格让它感觉稍微好一点，让你对自己能够买得起不是基本选择的东西感觉稍微好一点，因为它喂养了
your ego, it feeds some unconscious part of your mind that needs validation. Maybe you choose a certain pasta source because one time somebody really attractive who reminded you of your childhood crush, you saw them buying that pasta source. You don't remember that happening. But now that's the one you always buy. Maybe it was the one that your parents always chose. That is a huge influence. What our parents buy is often what, you know, continues to influence us, even when we think we're making our own conscious decision. You need to understand. the unconscious mind, again, because people are using it to direct your behavior, maybe against your actual wants. People can manipulate it. But also because imagine we're not in a
你的自我，它喂养了你潜意识中需要验证的一部分。也许你选择某种意大利面酱，因为有一次一个非常有吸引力的人，让你想起了你童年的暗恋对象，你看到他们在买那种意大利面酱。你不记得那件事发生了。但现在那是你总是买的那一种。也许那是你父母总是选择的那一种。这是一个巨大的影响。我们父母买的东西通常是我们，你知道，继续影响我们的东西，即使当我们认为我们在做出自己的意识决定时。你需要理解。潜意识，再次，因为人们正在使用它来引导你的行为，也许违背了你实际的愿望。人们可以操纵它。但也是因为想象我们不在
grocery store. Imagine we're around our friends. Imagine we're with somebody that we're dating. Those same automatic ingrained mental shortcuts that dictate your grocery choices also then dictate how you behave in those situations as well. like why you pick a fight over something small that seems to mean absolutely nothing, why you get so defensive towards criticism, even though you rationally know it's like a healthy part of a relationship. Why, for some reason, like your friend interrupting you drives you mad, but like she could be as late as she want,
杂货店。想象我们在朋友身边。想象我们和我们正在约会的人在一起。那些决定你杂货选择的同样的自动根深蒂固的心理捷径，也会决定你在这些情况下的行为。比如为什么你因为一些看起来毫无意义的小事而挑起争吵，为什么你对批评如此防御，即使你理性地知道这就像关系中健康的一部分。为什么，出于某种原因，你的朋友打断你让你发疯，但她可以随心所欲地迟到，
she could literally steal money from you and you don't care, but as soon as she's mad, like that's this weird disrespect that you don't know why you respond, but you do. your unconscious mind is trained to respond to whatever you repeatedly experience, rehearse and emotionally encode, especially when it happens early, often, or intensely. That is really how your unconscious mind is trained, early often or intensely, frequency, intensity, or the age at which it occurred. A big aspect that impacts our unconscious mind is obviously, you may have guessed this,
她可以从你那里偷钱，你不在乎，但一旦她疯了，就像那是你不知道为什么你会有反应的奇怪不尊重，但你确实有。你的潜意识被训练去响应你反复经历、排练和情感编码的任何事情，特别是当它发生得早、频繁或强烈时。这确实是你的潜意识被训练的方式，早、频繁或强烈，频率、强度或它发生的年龄。一个影响我们潜意识的巨大方面显然是，你可能已经猜到了，
our early learnings, our family, our childhood experiences, even, and some would say this, experiences you had in the womb or generationally. Literally, there is this idea called collective unconscious, which says that our deepest beliefs and our ways of seeing the world are spiritually inherited before our, before we even are conscious beings. Your unconscious mind is being formed way before your conscious mind even catches up. Whilst I think that's pretty hard to prove scientifically, and there's yet to be a lot of proof, scientific proof for it, we do know that you absorb the rules of your environment before you
我们早期的学习、我们的家庭、我们的童年经历，甚至，有些人会这么说，你在子宫里或代际经历的经历。字面上，有一个叫做集体潜意识的想法，它说我们最深层的信念和我们看待世界的方式是在我们甚至成为有意识的存在之前就在精神上继承的。你的潜意识在你意识赶上之前很久就已经形成了。虽然我认为这在科学上很难证明，而且目前还没有很多证据，科学证据支持它，但我们确实知道你在你意识到之前就吸收了你环境的规则
are consciously aware of them. Things like how love is shown, what happens when you're upset, whether mistakes when you were a child were punished or repaired, whether your needs were welcomed or inconvenient, whether you were bullied, how you were taught to behave, things that really traumatized you or excited you as a kid, they are what are creating the rules for your unconscious mind. And they become the template for how life works, how relationships work, how everything in the world works. Even in adulthood, your body will keep running these childhood rules until you consciously update them. And this is why therapeutic tools like, you know, like talk therapy or learning to
有意识地意识到它们。诸如爱是如何表现的，当你心烦意乱时会发生什么，当你还是个孩子时错误是受到惩罚还是修复，你的需求是受欢迎的还是不方便的，你是否被欺负，你被教导如何表现，那些真正让你感到创伤或兴奋的事情，它们正在为你的潜意识创造规则。它们成为了生活如何运作、关系如何运作、世界上一切如何运作的模板。即使在成年期，你的身体也会继续运行这些童年的规则，直到你自觉地更新它们。这就是为什么治疗工具，比如，你知道，比如谈话疗法或学习重新抚养自己或重新处理或第一次处理或创伤是如此有效。你知道，这些是我们不一定一直意识到的东西。我们有点知道它发生了。我们并没有真正得到它造成的伤口。直到你像真正像挖掘战壕一样深入挖掘，几乎像一个考古学家，你把这些东西带上来。与专业人士一起，对吧，你更了解自己，你真正理解是什么导致了你行为中的这些模式。那么你如何识别你的潜意识何时真正
reparent yourself or reprocessing or processing for the first time or trauma are so effective. You know, these are the stuff that we're not necessarily aware of all the time. We kind of know it happens. We don't really get the wounds that it's causing. And it's not until you like really like get in the trenches and like dig deep, almost like an archaeologist and you bring up this stuff. with a professional, right, that you get yourself a bit more and you really understand what causes these patterns in your behavior. So how can you recognize when your unconscious mind is really
以一种对你不利的方式引导事情？因为你的潜意识正在引导很多事情。其中一些很棒。我们不需要触及它。我们如何弄清楚我们什么时候需要？我们确实需要像做一些那种考古挖掘。正如弗洛伊德所说，会有迹象。但这可能不会是梦，或者令人不安的艺术或弗洛伊德式口误。那可能不是唯一的方法，那不是接触这个的最佳方式。
steering things in a way that isn't benefiting you? Because your unconscious mind is steering a lot. Some of it's great. We don't need to touch that. How do we figure out when we do? We do need to like do some of that. Again, archaeological digging. As Freud said, there will be signs. It's probably not going to be dreams, though, or disturbing art or Freudian slips. That's probably not the only way, that's not the best way to get access to this.
相反，我讨厌说，它可能将是你的行为和你的表现的自然后果。我希望我们可以通过梦来解释我们潜意识中所有错误的东西。那会容易得多。不，它可能将会有更多现实的、更现实的、有形的感觉。
Instead, and I hate to say, it's probably going to be the natural consequences of your actions and of your behavior. I wish we could interpret everything that was wrong with us unconsciously throughout dreams. It'd be a lot easier. No, it's probably going to have a bit more realistic, a more realistic, tangible feel to it.
相反，我很遗憾地说，这很可能是你行为和举止所带来的自然后果。我希望我们能通过梦境潜意识地解读出我们身上所有的问题。那样会容易得多。不，这很可能会有一种更现实、更具体的感觉。
one way to know is when you keep repeating a pattern even though consciously you want something different. You might genuinely want to rest, but you keep overworking and you feel terrible about it because you're not seeing your family or your friends, but you cannot stop. You might really want a healthy relationship. You really want to be with somebody who loves you, but you keep choosing emotionally unavailable people. Repetition with regret. you might really want to stand up for yourself and you really want to start that business and you really want to be a self-made success but when it comes down to it you put yourself you put yourself in a
了解这一点的方法之一是，当你明明在意识上想要改变，却依然不断重复某种模式时。你可能真心想休息，却不停地过度工作，并为此感到痛苦，因为你没时间陪伴家人或朋友，但你就是停不下来。你可能真心想要一段健康的感情，真心想和爱你的人在一起，但你却总是选择那些情感上无法回应你的人。这就是带着遗憾的重复。你可能真心想为自己挺身而出，真心想创业，真心想白手起家获得成功，但当真正面临抉择时，你却把自己……你把自己关在了一个
box you apologize you can't you know put yourself out there you feel this kind of stagnation like there is like this ceiling to how much you can achieve you know your wiring says to you that is not something that is available to us that is not who we are based on past experience experiences. That gap, that gap is important. The gap between what you consciously want and what you repeatedly do or believe is the clearest sign of an automatic reflex that is built on unconscious, unhelpful mechanisms. Another time that you can notice that your unconscious is like in control in a way that's not great is when your reactions feel bigger than the situation that is in front of you. A useful, a very useful tool or clue is when you feel this real sense of urgency to
盒子里，你道歉，你无法……你知道的，你无法展现真实的自己。你感到一种停滞不前，仿佛你所能取得的成就有一个天花板。你知道，你的大脑回路在告诉你，那不是我们能触及的，那不是我们这类人会做的事，这是基于过去的经历。那个差距，那个差距很重要。你意识上想要的和你反复去做或去相信的之间的差距，是潜意识中无益机制所引发的自动反射的最明显标志。另一个你可以注意到潜意识在以一种不好的方式掌控你的时刻，是当你发现自己的反应比眼前的实际情况要强烈得多的时候。一个非常有用的工具或线索是，当你感到一种强烈的紧迫感，想要
respond in a specific way to a situation, if it feels like I have to do this right now to feel okay, otherwise like I don't have any other way, I don't know any other way to respond to this. That is often the unconscious mind, trying just to reduce discomfort as efficiently as possible and it's just trying to protect you in the way that made sense in the past. If a small comment sends you into panic and rage and shut down and you just like don't know where that has come from, or if you find yourself like overreacting just like rapidly and then you feel super confused afterwards, that is often an automatic threat response. And these kinds of situations we are responding through memory.
以某种特定的方式去应对一个情况时，如果感觉“我必须现在这样做才能感到安心，否则我就没有别的办法了，我不知道还能怎么应对”，这通常就是潜意识在试图尽可能高效地减少不适感，它只是在试图以过去认为合理的方式保护你。如果一个小小的评论让你陷入恐慌、愤怒和封闭，而你不知道这种感觉从何而来，或者如果你发现自己反应过度，事后又感到非常困惑，这通常是一种自动的威胁反应。在这些情况下，我们是在通过记忆来做出反应。
and we're responding based on past meaning rather than what is actually happening in the present moment. And it definitely is a sign like something deeper is being activated or triggered here that maybe we're not aware of. Or maybe we are, but we don't want to think of. Just to give you some more examples. Like, I'm trying to think about what would be a good one. So for example, if your friend always chooses the restaurant and you start getting like really annoyed at them, really annoyed at them and you do not know why, is it really them or is it because you don't like being directed or because you're not in control of plants? Because somebody else choosing a restaurant probably shouldn't elicit that much of an emotional reaction,
我们是基于过去的意义，而不是基于当下正在发生的事情来做出反应。这绝对是一个信号，表明这里被激活或触发了一些更深层的东西，也许我们并没有意识到。或者也许我们意识到了，但不想去深想。再给你举几个例子。我在想什么例子比较好。比如，如果你的朋友总是决定去哪家餐厅，而你开始对他们感到非常恼火，非常恼火，却不知道为什么。真的是因为他们吗？还是因为你不喜欢被指挥，或者因为你无法掌控计划？因为别人选择餐厅这件事，本不该引起那么大的情绪反应，
but you think it really says something about you. Or if your partner doesn't say, I love you back in like the specific right tone at the right time and like you go into this full tizzy, is it about them? Or is it that you like maybe always secretly question whether anyone could truly love you because your parents didn't show you that much affection? or because a relationship in the past made you feel worthless. It's worth asking, once you are aware of these markers and these reactions that just seem really disproportionate, you are basically more aware than I would say 90% of people, probably
但你觉得这确实反映了你自身的问题。或者，如果你的伴侣没有在特定的时间以特定的语气回应你的“我爱你”，而你陷入了彻底的慌乱，这是关于他们的问题吗？还是因为你内心深处总是怀疑是否有人能真正爱你，因为你的父母没有给你足够的关爱？或者因为过去的一段感情让你感到自己毫无价值。值得一问的是，一旦你意识到这些标志和那些看起来非常不成比例的反应，你基本上就已经比我所说的90%的人更具觉察力了，可能
higher. So like noticing it feels very shameful sometimes and feels very much like awkward and weird. And I actually think that's the greatest place to start in that discomfort of recognizing behaviors you don't like about yourself. Because it isn't your fault. It definitely isn't your fault most of the time that like this is who you are and this is how you are programmed and this is what your unconscious mind chooses to prioritize. It is your responsibility though, which really sucks.
还要更高。所以，注意到这一点有时会让人感到非常羞耻，感到非常尴尬和奇怪。而我实际上认为，在承认自己不喜欢自己的行为所带来的不适感中，正是最好的起点。因为这不是你的错。大多数时候，这绝对不是你的错，这不是你的本意，也不是你被编程的方式，更不是你潜意识选择优先考虑的事情。但这确实是你的责任，这真的很糟糕。
It's just another one of those extra fun things about being an adult. But we can definitely do it. We can definitely take responsibilities for these behaviors and change the outcome and change the behavioral loop. So we're going to take one final break here and then when we come back, I want to give you three ways to do this and to reprogram your unconscious mind as much as we possibly can as conscious individuals. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of men.
这只是成年人生活中又一个“额外有趣”的事情。但我们绝对可以做到。我们绝对可以为这些行为负责，改变结果，改变行为循环。所以我们在这里进行最后一次休息，回来后，我想给你提供三种方法来做到这一点，并尽可能以有意识的个体身份重新编程你的潜意识。所以请留下来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了
mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will. come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行交流，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真心相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在这个世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“TWO%”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了莉尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和莉尔·金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。“说实话，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。”“我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。”“我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以……”“谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。”“是的。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。”“真的吗？”
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
“是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。”在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。“有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。”
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
“而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。”史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。“因为你觉得作为一个好人很重要，所以你才在这个地球上？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。”
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free Our Heart Radio app.
“绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。”加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们将就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct?
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。“你在这个特定的测试中伪造了两次，对吧？”
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。“我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。”他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。“我的大脑被震撼了。”
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着这一季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。“女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被控欺诈罪。”在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never. Mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
第一条法则，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条法则，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》这一新季中……“天哪，这是同一个人。”
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I personally think one of the biggest signs of intelligence in somebody is
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。“我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？”警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。“我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。”收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我个人认为，一个人智慧的最大标志之一是
choosing not just to accept your situation or learn behavior for what it is. Choosing not just to say, like, this is the way I am and this is how I've always been. So why do I have to change? But instead, instead, taking action on behalf of your better self and on behalf of the person you want to be, even if you are not there yet. In fact, research has shown, research is shown time and time again that one of the biggest signs of low mental flexibility and therefore low mental intelligence, or emotional intelligence, I should say, is being unable to take accountability or see any issue with our own
选择不仅仅是接受你的处境或习得的行为。选择不仅仅是说：“我就是这样，我一直都是这样，所以我为什么要改变？”而是采取行动，为了更好的自己，为了你想成为的那个人，即使你还没有达到那个目标。事实上，研究一次又一次地表明，心理灵活性低，从而导致心理智力或情感智力低的最大标志之一，就是无法承担责任或无法看到我们自身行为中的任何问题。
behavior. That is not going to be us, though. That is not going to be us because we know, we know what we're responsible for. Now we're going to change it. Recognizing ways you may be self-sabotaging is not a weakness. Most people will never do this in their entire lives. So this is what we're going to do next. The first step, according to the incredible author. Brianna Weist, I think her name is Brianna West. You will know her though.
但我们不会那样。我们不会那样，因为我们知道，我们知道我们要为自己负责。现在我们要改变它。认识到你可能在自我破坏的方式并不是一种弱点。大多数人一生中永远不会这样做。所以接下来我们要这样做。第一步，根据不可思议的作家布里安娜·威斯特（我想她的名字是布里安娜·威斯特，你们会认识她的）的说法。
She wrote the book 101 essays to change the way you think. She also wrote the pivot year. The Mountain is You. I think she has another book coming out. But one of the best things that she said about this, about this rewiring of the unconscious is if you want to
她写了《101 Essays to Change the Way You Think》。她还写了《The Pivot Year》、《The Mountain Is You》。我想她还有另一本书要出版。但关于这一点，关于潜意识的重新连接，她所说的最好的事情之一是：如果你想
change your behavior and you want to rewire how your unconsciousness or unconscious brain responds to things, you have to signal to your subconscious and your unconscious that another reality is possible. Essentially, you have to be able to imagine a new scenario and a better scenario for yourself. And the more you practice that imagined scenario in your brain by rehearsing it, by visualizing it, the more it feels real. So you've recognized the response that you want to change. Now you are essentially reprogramming the
改变你的行为，你想重新连接你的潜意识或无意识大脑对事物的反应方式，你必须向你的潜意识发出信号，表明另一种现实是可能的。本质上，你必须能够为你自己想象一个新的场景和一个更好的场景。你越是在大脑中通过排练、通过可视化来练习那个想象中的场景，它就越真实。所以你已经识别出了你想要改变的反应。现在你本质上是在重新编程
outcome that, the possibility of a different outcome that could come afterwards, your brain often treats objective reality and your thoughts about a potential reality or your imagination is the same. And that means that if you think it can be true, your brain starts to believe it as well. That's cognitive rewiring. It's literally the same neurological patterns that create anxiety just in the reverse, right? Your brain, like your brain cooks up these, like, what if possibilities and overinvest in them because it can't always tell imagined reality from actual reality. In this situation, though, we're going to overthink the best case scenario. We are like reverse engineering this to help us out. As Brianna says, you have to be willing to see it's possible
结果，即可能在之后出现的不同结果的可能性。你的大脑通常把客观现实和你关于潜在现实的想法或你的想象视为同一回事。这意味着如果你认为它是真的，你的大脑也开始相信它。这就是认知重塑。这实际上与产生焦虑的神经模式相同，只是方向相反，对吧？你的大脑会编造出这些“如果……会怎样”的可能性，并过度投入其中，因为它并不总是能区分想象的现实和实际的现实。但在这种情况下，我们要对最佳情况进行过度思考。我们就像是在逆向工程，来帮助我们自己。正如布里安娜所说，你必须愿意看到它是可能的，
before the reality of possibility follows. Whether that is in a relationship, whether that is imagining how you are going to break out of your cycle of dating emotionally unavailable people, you have to imagine that that's possible. Whether it is breaking out of a pattern of rage and anger, you have to imagine it's possible first. Whether it is breaking out of a pattern of not communicating with your friends and always having these dramatic friendship blowups, if you cannot imagine a different way of doing it, you're not going to be able to do it. So part of this practice is like almost kind of like a creative writing, creative rewiring exercise of like write your own adventure, write your own ending.
然后可能性的现实才会随之而来。无论是在一段关系中，还是想象你将如何打破与情感上无法回应你的人约会的循环，你都必须想象这是可能的。无论是打破愤怒和暴躁的模式，你都必须先想象它是可能的。无论是打破不与朋友沟通、总是发生戏剧性友谊破裂的模式，如果你无法想象一种不同的做法，你就无法做到。所以这种练习的一部分就像是一种创意写作、创意重塑练习，写你自己的冒险，写你自己的结局。
How is this going to go? Second, once you have the imagined alternative scenario, just keep the programming really, really simple. Choose one behavior, one reaction, one automatic choice you make that you don't particularly like and target that. This was advice that was written about in the new scientists in 2018. They actually did this whole series on like reprogramming your unconscious if you want to pay for a subscription. But essentially what they said or what the author of this article said was that we have to start small.
这会怎么发展？第二，一旦你有了想象中的替代方案，就让编程保持非常、非常简单。选择一种行为、一种反应、一种你做出但不特别喜欢的自动选择，并针对它。这是2018年《新科学家》杂志上写到的建议。他们实际上做了一个关于重新编程潜意识的完整系列。但本质上他们所说的，或者这篇文章的作者所说的是，我们必须从小处着手。
We have to start on the most micro level to gain access to our unconscious and rewire it. So creating a singular if then plan where, the then is the desired behavior, that is what we're talking about. If I'm in this situation, then this is how I'm going to respond. There's actually such strong evidence. It's been written about so many times. This is not an original idea for me, by the way, at all. This has been written about and studied so often that one of these simplest ways to gain more control over automatic impulses is to pre-decide what your response is going to be in advance. It's also a way that people recover from addiction, you know, one behavior at a time, there was a major 2006
我们必须从最微观的层面开始，以获得对我们潜意识的访问权并重新连接它。所以创建一个单一的“如果……那么……”计划，其中“那么”是期望的行为，这就是我们所说的。如果我处于这种情况，那么我将这样回应。实际上有非常强有力的证据。它已经被写过很多次了。顺便说一句，这对我来说根本不是一个原创的想法。这已经被写过和研究过很多次了，以至于获得对自动冲动更多控制的最简单方法之一，就是提前决定你的反应将是什么。这也是人们从成瘾中恢复的一种方式，你知道，一次一个行为。2006年有一项重大的
meta-analysis, so a little bit old now, but this big meta-analysis that pulled together results from dozens of studies, and they tested what these are called. These are called implementation intentions, right? Those if-then plans, like if it's 10 p.m., then I'm in bed. If it's the morning, then I'm not on my phone, that's a bad one. Like, if I feel the urge to people please, then I will email somebody and say, I'll get back to you, then I will give myself 20 minutes to respond. If I'm angry at my partner, then I'll take a walk, those kind of implementation intentions across all these studies, people who had these in place, people who had the imagined better scenario, were significantly more likely to follow through on their new habits.
元分析，虽然现在有点旧了，但这个大型元分析汇集了数十项研究的结果，他们测试了这些被称为“执行意图”的东西，对吧？那些“如果……那么……”计划，比如“如果是晚上10点，那么我就上床睡觉。如果是早上，那么我就不看手机（那是个坏习惯）。比如，如果我感到取悦他人的冲动，那么我会给某人发邮件说，我会回复你的，然后我会给自己20分钟的时间来回复。如果我对伴侣生气，那么我会去散步。”这些执行意图在所有这些研究中，那些有这些计划的人，那些有想象中更好场景的人，比那些只设定了一个笼统的改变愿望的人，更有可能坚持他们的新习惯。
intentions than people who just set a general broad desire to change. So people who are like, I want to, I want to be better. I want to be a better person. I want to be healthier, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. They weren't able to really do it. But when you could say, this is my trigger, or this is the situation I normally unconsciously respond to, and this is how I want to respond differently, when you could really identify A and B, your chances of success skyrocketed. And the explanation for that, sorry, just to drill into this a little bit more, the explanation for that is that the if part is the crucial part, because it makes you more sensitive to what is queuing the automatic response that you would normally perform. If, the if is making you aware of what in your environment triggers a response. What in your environment makes you particularly sensitive?
意图比那些只设定了一个笼统的改变愿望的人要强得多。所以那些说“我想，我想变得更好。我想成为一个更好的人。我想变得更健康，等等等等”的人，他们无法真正做到。但当你能说，“这是我的触发点，或者这是我通常潜意识里会做出反应的情况，而这是我想要的不同反应方式”，当你能真正识别出A和B时，你成功的几率就会飙升。对此的解释是——抱歉，再深入一点——对此的解释是，“如果”部分是关键部分，因为它让你对是什么在提示你通常会执行的自动反应更加敏感。如果……“如果”让你意识到环境中是什么触发了反应。环境中是什么让你特别敏感？
what in your environment your past has made you particularly reactive to and then it interrupts the normal loop that your unconscious or automatic behaviors would want to perform and is like this is our exit then we will do something else another way to feel more in control of the impulses of the unconscious mind especially the ones again I keep saying the ones we don't want your unconscious mind just great things but another way to feel in control of those that we don't particularly enjoy is really simply to just move slower. When we talk about impulses, we're often really talking about bottom up automatic, like automatic processing and like automatic emotional responses, right?
环境中是什么让你过去特别容易产生反应，然后它中断了你的潜意识或自动行为想要执行的正常循环，就像是“这是我们的出口，然后我们将做点别的”。另一种感觉更能控制潜意识冲动的方法，特别是那些我一直说的我们不想要的冲动，其实很简单，就是动作慢一点。当我们谈论冲动时，我们通常谈论的是自下而上的自动处理和自动情绪反应，对吧？
It's coming from something very deep in us. And these responses are often generated by much older ancient brain systems. the ones that would have come about first, the amygdala, the limbic system, the midbrain structures. Literally, if you looked at a cross-section of the brain, they are right in the center. They're the most protected because they're the most important. These systems, they are fast, they are efficient, they are designed for survival. It doesn't want you to wait for nuance. Your automatic behaviours don't care about your long-term goals.
它来自我们内心非常深处的东西。这些反应通常是由更古老的大脑系统产生的。那些最先出现的系统，杏仁核、边缘系统、中脑结构。从字面上看，如果你看大脑的横截面，它们就在中心。它们是最受保护的，因为它们是最重要的。这些系统，它们很快，它们很有效，它们是为了生存而设计的。它不想让你等待细微差别。你的自动行为不在乎你的长期目标。
They don't want to consult you about. how your reaction might meet your vision of your ideal self. When you are stressed, when you are sleep deprived, when you are overstimulated, when you are emotionally flooded, the balance between your limbic system and your prefrontal cortex shifts so that your ability to intentionally interrupt a behavior
它们不想咨询你，你的反应可能如何符合你理想自我的愿景。当你感到压力时，当你睡眠不足时，当你过度刺激时，当你情绪泛滥时，你的边缘系统和前额叶皮层之间的平衡就会发生偏移，以至于你故意中断行为的能力
or intentionally interrupt, I don't know, reaction, it just goes way down. Like, it's hard to get in front of that bus. in high arousal states, you are, again, more likely to return to the default or to your habitual behaviours. And so your window for tolerance of discomfort and your ability to interrupt it, it just narrows. Slowing down, on the other hand, interrupts that like that cascade of stuff that's happening. From a neurobiological perspective, deliberately, you know, reducing even your walking pace. Deliberately. Deliberately.
或者故意中断反应的能力，就会大幅下降。就像，很难挡在那辆车前面。在高唤醒状态下，你再次更有可能回到默认状态或你的习惯性行为。因此，你对不适的容忍窗口和你中断它的能力就会缩小。另一方面，慢下来会中断那种正在发生的级联反应。从神经生物学的角度来看，故意地，你知道，甚至减少你的行走速度。故意地。故意地。
making yourself in less of a rush all the time. Slowing down your breathing, slowing down your speech, slowing down your physical movement, slowing down how you eat even, whether you rush breakfast over the counter or you sit down and enjoy it. Slowing down all that stuff increases parasympathetic
让自己一直不那么匆忙。放慢你的呼吸，放慢你的语速，放慢你的身体动作，甚至放慢你吃东西的速度，无论你是匆忙吃早餐还是坐下来享受它。放慢所有这些事情都会增加副交感
nervous system activity, which means better emotional regulation and stronger like top-down control rather than bottom up response. You are literally making it biologically, neurologically easier to choose a better, a better outcome for yourself rather than just reacting. You can't manage what is unconscious if you are always in a reactive state. It's just not possible.
神经系统的活动，这意味着更好的情绪调节和更强的自上而下的控制，而不是自下而上的反应。你实际上是在生物学上、神经学上让为自己选择一个更好的结果变得更容易，而不是仅仅做出反应。如果你总是处于反应状态，你就无法管理潜意识。这根本是不可能的。
So this is probably the most important thing of all. Do the talk therapy, do the inner child healing, do all of that to the historical work, but if your nervous system is not regulated, if you are not going about life more intentionally, and I feel like intentionality is such a buzzword, but it's true, if you do not work on these high-level intentions and slowing down your life and reducing stress in whatever way you can, I know it's a busy life, but reducing stress in whatever way you can, your ability to signal to your body that you want to perform this new set of narratives and that you want to respond differently, it's going to be very, very difficult.
所以这可能是最重要的事情。去做谈话疗法，去做内在小孩的治愈，去做所有的历史工作，但如果你的神经系统没有得到调节，如果你不是更刻意地生活（我觉得“刻意”是一个很流行的词，但这是真的），如果你不致力于这些高水平的意图，放慢你的生活，并以任何你能做到的方式减少压力（我知道生活很忙，但以任何你能做到的方式减少压力），你向身体发出信号表明你想要执行这套新叙事并想要做出不同反应的能力，将会非常、非常困难。
But I still think you're able to do it. I still think that even just recognizing to begin with the role of your unconscious mind and what it's kind of doing, not doing to you, but what it's trying to do for you, based on the past, based on past hurt, based on past fear, trauma, even good things. That is a great place to begin. I know for me, and I feel like I've been talking about this a lot in recent episodes. You can tell I'm really, this is what I'm going through at the moment, but my big thing has been realizing how I unconsciously respond to social threats, especially with my friends, and
但我仍然认为你有能力做到。我仍然认为，仅仅是开始认识到潜意识的作用，以及它在做什么——不是在对你做什么，而是基于过去、基于过去的伤害、基于过去的恐惧、创伤，甚至好的事情，它在试图为你做什么——这是一个很好的起点。我知道对我来说，我觉得我在最近的几集中谈论了很多这个话题。你可以看出我真的……这就是我目前正在经历的事情，但我的大事是意识到我如何潜意识地对社交威胁做出反应，特别是在我的朋友们身上，以及
reflecting on, you know, how when I was a kid, like I wasn't accepted and I was bullied and I didn't have many friends and I was very lonely. And so I would always have this weird reaction when like people would hang out without me or, I don't know, things of that nature would happen where I would get really irritated and I would, I would self-sabotage in a way where I would put even more distance between myself and that friend, even when they were kind of like, hey, what the heck is going on? That's been a big thing for me, realizing that unconsciously, everything that my brain is trying to do is to make life safer for me and is trying to protect me from past hurt.
反思，你知道，当我还是个孩子的时候，我没有被接受，我被欺负，我没有很多朋友，我非常孤独。所以当人们不带我出去玩，或者，我不知道，发生类似的事情时，我总是会有这种奇怪的反应，我会变得非常恼火，我会以一种方式自我破坏，我会把我和那个朋友之间的距离拉得更远，即使他们当时有点像，“嘿，到底发生了什么？”这对我是件大事，意识到潜意识里，我的大脑试图做的一切都是为了让我的生活更安全，并试图保护我免受过去的伤害。
And the thing is, is that I'm not in that situation anymore. I'm not that child or that teenager or that kid who was like feeling very socially rejected. I'm an adult who has a brilliant life and who is really focused on brilliant friendships. Those patterns from my past don't fit here anymore. And if I keep them up and if I keep performing them, like I'm going to lose a really good thing. So just noticing it and being as intentional as possible and being like, I don't want to be this person anymore. Just one of the most brilliant things that you can do or start like not just in your 20s, but at any age.
问题是，我不再处于那种境地了。我不再是那个感到社交被拒绝的孩子、青少年或小孩了。我是一个成年人，拥有精彩的生活，并且非常专注于精彩的友谊。那些过去的模式不再适合这里了。如果我保持它们，如果我继续执行它们，我就会失去一件非常好的事情。所以只要注意到它，并尽可能地刻意，并表现得像“我不想再做这样的人了”。这只是你可以做或开始做的最精彩的事情之一，不仅是在你20多岁时，而是在任何年龄。
You can be in your 60s and it's still going to be great. You could be in your 90s and this is still an effective, wonderful thing for us to do. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope it's given you some insight, stirred up some conversation. As always, thank you to our brilliant researcher,
你可以在60多岁时，它仍然会很棒。你可以在90多岁时，这仍然是对我们来说有效、美妙的事情。所以我希望你喜欢这一集。我希望它给了你一些见解，引发了一些对话。一如既往，感谢我们出色的研究员
Libby Colbert for her help with this episode. So much research went into this and it's just like always such a fascinating topic to return to, whether you're like in the intro stages of psychology, like more advanced. I feel like it's one of my, yeah, it's one of my favorite things to discuss. If you are listening on Spotify, leave a little brain emoji below so I know that you made it to the end of the episode. And thank you for sticking around. I very much appreciate it. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram, on Substack. If you want the, yeah, if you want
利比·科尔伯特对这一集的帮助。为此投入了大量的研究，无论你是在心理学的入门阶段还是更高级的阶段，这总是像一个如此迷人的话题。如果你在Spotify上收听，请在下面留下一个大脑表情符号，这样我就知道你听到了这一集的结尾。感谢你的坚持。我非常感激。确保你在Instagram、Substack上关注我们。如果你想要，是的，如果你想要
the links to this article and to look at all the research we used, you can also watch us now on Netflix. If you are in the US or Canada, please tag me in your pictures, tag me in your stories of you watching the podcast. The vibe is amazing. You can see all these cool props behind me right now. It just brings, I don't know, a whole deeper level to what we're doing today and what we're talking about. So thank you again for listening. Hopefully I see you over on Netflix if you are in the US or Canada elsewhere. I'm sorry. I can't help you with that right now, but hopefully soon and until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very shortly.
这篇文章的链接并查看我们使用的所有研究，你现在也可以在Netflix上观看我们。如果你在美国或加拿大，请在你的照片中标记我，在你的故事中标记我，展示你在观看播客。氛围太棒了。你现在可以看到我身后所有这些很酷的道具。它只是带来，我不知道，一个更深层次的层面，关于我们今天正在做的事情和我们正在谈论的事情。所以再次感谢你的收听。希望如果你们在美国或加拿大，我能在Netflix上见到你们。在其他地方，我很抱歉。我现在帮不了你，但希望很快，直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。我们很快就会再谈。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“TWO%”。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。“从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。”我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild... I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。“84年是一个疯狂的……我的意思是，那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。”在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何地方进行这些对话都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。“你在这个特定的测试中伪造了两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？”“我伪造了一次测试。”
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。“我的大脑被震撼了。”我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own. own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart
随着这一季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过，她们采取了行动。“我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。”在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。这是一个iHeart
podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客。保证人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。